[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
oui
[Musique]
il
on a hâte que le travail reprenne
on attend des informations du
gouvernement puisqu'ils nous ont dit
qu'il y avait un protocole en place on
n'a pas les détails du coup
on aimerait connaître un peu les
différentes étapes qui préconise pour
notre milieu
en tout cas on se prépare on se prépare
à toute éventualité et comme ça on sera
prêt dès que la reprise sera possible
bah moi j'y crois à moitié on espère
vous voir si c'est vraiment ça va
réouvrir on a un peu marre des proses
espoir et j'espère que six arrêts au
cours de huit fois ci ça pas à bordeaux
mais pas paris ou par territoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette année j'ai voulu faire un truc
propre et j'ai merci quand même plus de
6000 euros pour pour faire sa terrasse
en bonne et due forme qui soit qu'ils
soient jolies dans le paysage quoi
[Musique]
on pourrait juste déplacer ces marquages
et je pense que tout le monde trouverait
son compte
je pense que c'est une meilleure
solution que de me laisser sans terrasse
sans la possibilité d'ouvrir avec huit
personnes au chômage et et moi en tant
qu'entrepreneur dans encore dans la
difficulté et aux crochets des aides de
l'état
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]